it's red and pricey it's a critter and a
delicacy it's the creme de la creme of
seafood but this beloved summertime
favorite was once thought of as the poor
man's food say what it is said that in
the early 16th century as the first
pilgrims began to settle in Bay Area's
of America that the oceans overfloweth
with lobster no literally they
overfloweth imagined a shore with a
lobster wall two feet tall as one would
expect the settlers ate them up until
like anything eaten three times a day
they got sick of them eventually deeming
them the cockroaches of the sea after
that lobsters were used as fertilizer
fish bait and ultimately prison food
they were fed so often to inmates that
there was even a law enacted to protect
said inmates from cruel and unusual
lobster punishment so then how did
lobster become the succulent delicacy we
all know and love fast forward to the
mid 1800 canned food became a thing as
did the railroad lobsters were canned
and shipped to middle America at the
same time middle Americans started
traveling to New England for fresh
lobster by the late 1880s prices began
to surge and by World War two lobsters
became the pricey specialty we've all
grown to enjoy
these are nachos Dec golden crispy chips
gooey melted cheese mounds of toppings
galore
they are delicious they're named after a
man a man named nacho
this was Ignacio Anaya known to friends
and foes alike as nacho in 1943 Ignacio
was a Maitre D' at this restaurant the
old victory club Piedras Negras Mexico a
border town of jalapenos through from
the Eagle Pass Texas home of Fort Duncan
an army base filled with military men
and families one day a group of Army
wives crossed the border they shopped
they got hungry they went to the victory
Club the chef wasn't there but Ignacio
Maitre D' didn't want to turn the woman
away so he sprang into action
grabbing tortillas shredded cheddar
cheese and jalapenos
he put his creation into the other
pensively
he served it to the army wives they
loved the tourney to Texas they spread
the ELN jelly O'Dell nacho the gospel of
the nacho nacho specialis became so
adored and renowned Ignacio opened up
his own restaurant
the creatively named nachos restaurant
you probably recognize these ice-cream
pellets as the ice cream of the future
they're dippin dots a summertime staple
but this confectionery treat didn't
start as well ice cream
it started as Cal feed dippin dots were
invented in the 80s not by an ice cream
brand but by a microbiologist Curtis
Jones
specialized in cryogenics in 1987 he was
working for a biotech company in
Kentucky trying to figure out how to
make food for farm animals more
efficient his big breakthrough came when
he flash froze cattle feed 350 degrees
below zero
which produce small pellets
serendipitously Curtis loved making ice
cream next thing he knew he was using
liquid nitrogen to freeze ice cream at
extremely low temperatures and ended up
with small beads of it when eaten the
natural heat of the mouth melted the
beads and thus dippin dots was born a
year later he formed the company out of
his parents garage in Illinois but there
was a problem Curtis had nowhere to sell
the product dippin dots need to be
stored at such a cold temperature that
it made it impossible for grocery stores
to house the tasty treat so he got
creative and marketed his product to
alternate locations now they're sold at
amusement parks festivals zoos and other
summertime destinations but whether or
not they really are the ice cream of
your future we'll just have to wait and
see
Chinese takeout that convenient hunger
buster that can turn up at your door
within minutes in a perfectly packaged
Chinese takeout box funny thing about
that Chinese takeout box it's actually
American yeah
although the box's folds in style were
inspired by Japanese origami the
packaging is a uniquely Western
invention in 1894 chicago-based inventor
Frederic weeks Wilcox patented the paper
pail a single piece of paper folded into
a leak-proof container
fastened with a wire handle around this
time California experienced a huge
influx of Chinese immigrants many came
here in search of gold bringing along
their cuisine and culture fast-forward
to the post-war boom every family is
moving to the idyllic suburbs
conveniences paramount and Chinese
takeout starts to take off mm-hmm then
in the 1970s a graphic designer
added a pagoda to the side of the box
along with a faux Asian thank you on top
from then on the containers became a
fixture of the Chinese takeout industry
even though they have never been used in
China ketchup so American it's basically
the red in red white and blue right and
that red clearly is from the tomatoes
the ketchup is made from
but that wasn't always the case the
first recorded recipe for ketchup comes
from China and for more than a thousand
years
it wasn't even made with tomatoes it was
made with fish guts fish intestines
bladder and stomach all mixed together
with salt then sealed and heated in the
hot Summer Sun for 20 days that was the
original ketchup a fermented fish paste
that dates back to 6th century China it
was popular throughout Southeast Asia
and British and Dutch settlers who
arrived in the 1600s loved the stuff
over time they brought ketchup home to
Europe and added their own modifications
including beer mushrooms walnuts oysters
strawberries and peaches by the mid
1700s English ketchup was a mainstay on
British dinner tables and as colonists
went west it soon made its way across
the pond
that's where Tomatoes come in they're
native to the Americas and it's rumored
Europeans once believed they were
poisonous but poisonous they were not in
1812 a Philadelphia horticulturalist and
scientist by the name of James Meese
introduced tomatoes into the mix he
published a tomato ketchup recipe that
was the beginning of a new Crimson era
from there many different iterations
were concocted and by the end of the
18th century the New York Tribune called
tomato ketchup America's national
condiment that was on every table in the
land which brings us back to this tomato
ketchup is here to stay and I for one
don't miss the fish guts
salmon sushi isn't Japanese it's
Norwegian huh okay here's the story
until about 1995 raw salmon was not
consumed in Japan and this was for one
big reason Pacific salmon has parasites
oh so no salmon sushi sashimi no spicy
salmon nothing what no one but obviously
that all changed thanks in part to this
guy yes my my name is Beorn Eric Koston
Norway had a problem they had a lot of
salmon and too small a market looking
East they set their sights on Japan a
country that loves raw fish so much it's
willing to pay five times the price yes
for sushi grade so noir we formed a
committee and hired born from 1986 to
1991 I worked for okay Japan their job
was to convince Japanese consumers that
Atlantic salmon was safe to consume raw
and this was hard just take for example
pork if some guy from Norway came here
and said here ear pork meat raw it's
safe it's really yummy we'd be like man
you're crazy it was basically a matter
of perception so we had to change the
whole country number Buuren and his team
got to work they made the first ever
salmon rolls and serve them to
businessmen in Japan which they didn't
like for a long time it took actually 10
years ok I get the proper breakthrough
in the market so there it is salmon
sushi didn't exist before 1995 Bjorn on
behalf of the world we thank you